[Music]
hey guys in this video we are going to
talk about new season 8 photos and many
teases including a spoiler of your own
blackmailing Cersei where is possibly
turning the gun company against Cersei
a sledgehammer the truth behind Joshua
parentage coming for Jon and the claw
game ball being officially announced
we'll also be talking about new details
regarding a battle for Winterfell let's
start with the photo of all of our
favorite characters standing shoulder to
shoulder for one final group photo
ultimate characters except for bran
ginger eat or moon Qyburn erm Podrick
are missing does it mean that the fates
of these missing characters are sealed
or is it supposed to foreshadow
something else an actors who play bran
answers to have certain regulations in
their contracts that forbid them from
being in the same room together and set
so that's probably the reason why bran
is missing I'm not sure why the other
five are missing but I doubt it for
shadows their doomed fate since many of
the characters we see here will perish
before given transcends and yet they're
here this photo is taken on the master
King's Landing said the crew built a
Titanic story of symbolist the same set
which parts were burned down by live
part techniques or in other words
Dragons will burn down some of the most
popular King's Landing locations in
season eight we also have this new shot
of Danny which is definitely from the
season 8 premiere the serie marching
towards Winterfell with their armies may
be unsullied in particular in the shot
Jon to the track II and the rest of
their crew starts coming around as well
then we have Brienne in Davos in the
great hole of interval this is also for
the first episode and what's going on
here is a huge meeting Amina fell in
which almost all the main characters of
the series John Dana Tyrion Sansa
etcetera discussing the night king and
in fences of the Northmen FL right after
jumpers ends the North's new ally and
best hope Dana Targaryen then we have a
look at the stark sisters
sense scenario sophie Turner reveals
sense that the season is very much
enjoying becoming a leader in her own
right and this year there are certain
challenges by people who threaten it
given what we have seen thus far and
what Intel we have received this
conflict will firstly be with Danny a
sensible not acceptor as good as John
did or as good as our evil there will be
some tension between them in the first
episode
but this could also mean that since I
might make a move against her biggest
enemy Cersei Lannister will see as
Ferrari amazingly instead there's this
split vitória between trying to be who
she wants to be getting back to back to
that naivete in a sense with her family
and her unfinished business what this
means is that Arya will stick with her
family and fight for NFL against the
night king in Episode three but a minute
up falls MN arya learns of sources yet
another betrayal over her family she'll
have to say a temporary goodbye to her
family and go to finish her infamous
list speaking of family Rory McCann
hints at a confrontation between the
hound and mountain by saying there will
be a chance of squaring up to his
brother and facing these demons ladies
and gentlemen cleganebowl is going down
here's a shot of Cersei Lannister
emilina Harry who plays Cersei has to
say it's even more interesting Lina says
as usual with Cersei she's trapped in a
web of her own making what's the nature
of this fab Lina did not give any detail
of course by looking on yours father I
want he's got to say about his season 8
bath it's more than obvious that Lina is
talking about Cersei being trapped in
neurons hands after she is so foolishly
that you'll make a contract with the gun
company and making him so powerful
overall pilot is baek urine said this
urine wants to become the king of the
Seven Kingdoms yet he's also
blackmailing star saying you're on his
blackmailing starts Ava the gun company
and his iron fleet sir says got to marry
earned or he will leave with his fleet
and turned the gun company against her
as he might be Cersei who pay them but
it's yon who made the deal with them and
it's urine whose name is on the contract
that's why Cersei is trapped in a web of
her own making and that's how her own is
blackmailing her moving to the next shot
of John and Danny the Westeros power
couple with John's usual brooding face
and no one dressed get Harrington
explains the end of the world might be
coming soon but at least he's in love
with somebody and knows who he is and
then comes a sledgehammer his parentage
revealed will be a huge blow to John and
his relationship with Danny and it's not
surprising it'll be interesting to see
how Danny will react to it as well as we
all know a sledgehammer to Jeremy likely
come from brain or Sam the only two
people beside Howland who know the
secret about John Snow and it will
finally come out in the first episodes
of the final season an actor who plays
Sam said this Sam is really feeling the
responsibility of this information but
he no of John would rather hear this
from Sam than anybody else is this a
confirmation that same will be the one
to reveal John the truth or did he say
that just to throw us away you decide
Sam and Bryan discovered the truth
together but Sam would probably be a
better messenger
given brains detachment from his family
and weird behavior ever since he became
the three-eyed Raven brand seen here in
black and white may loosen up a bit in
season eight or at least according to an
actor Isaac MCS right who promises to
see a slightly wiser brain this year
who's less slightly robot overload
emilia clarke this is Danny's fate with
there's so much she has seen and
witnessed and been through a lost and
suffered and hurt she's been working for
this her entire existence in the next
shot we have the reunited lanes two
brothers hearings trying to figure out
what he really is in this storm of
negotiations Peter Dinklage said for
whatever he means or whatever it
foreshadows some point to Tyrians
already much discussed betrayal on this
channel we shall see and according to
Nikolaj coster-waldau Jaime's choosing
to do what he believes is right fighting
for the good side and been earning
sources right but giving Cersei in
season 8 episode 5 upon he finds out she
plans to burn the entire capital to the
ground by using wildfire including 1
million innocent people as well as John
10 in their armies will come there after
the fall of NFL and will be fighting the
night king and his army inside would be
also the right choice that I say spoiler
alert well it's entitled moving on to
Melisandre well Sandra is definitely on
a mission says carries on holding it's
not much but I will add what I can no
central in the first episode be able
Ennis I will get a few shots over what
we also know is the null Sanjay will at
some point return a Westeros and in my
opinion she will return either of
eternal force or even more likely that
our being more powerful than ever before
more magic things to come from El
Sanchez that I guarantee we also have
shot some sandy grave warmth in Greyjoy
Gillian brilliantly their little
captions but it's not giving away or
hinting anything then there's this
Chateau Varys Kenneth hill says versus
effective as always what is mean semper
shadows is very stirring the gun company
against our senior persuading them to
fight for the less Rhaegar son aegon
targaryen
since after all black red dragon is
tillage
we have been listening over and over
again how the gun company have never
broken a contract that then breaking it
and supporting targaryen seems like such
an obvious twist of the final season
additionally the gun company have
already broken a contract in the books
and you guessed who was reason a
Targaryen next we have Jory and Glen's
saying this has been given the greatest
challenges surrounding he'll be tested
like never before I can already see
Jerry protecting Danny who's giving a
birth while Jon fight the enemies
something similar today in protecting
pregnant Liana well Rhaegar was fighting
on the Trident finally we have sir Davos
Whitley and Cunningham speaking the
truth effects visible people have been
waiting for over the years there have
also been many covers released but the
most interesting one being the one with
nat king with fans going crazy about his
seven point star pupils contacts or CGI
the night Kings eyes are purposely made
this way and one can only wonder what it
means
hence our even for shadows the
seven-point star is the holy text in the
faith of the seven its title is a
reference to the seven-point star used
as a symbol of the faith which signifies
the seven in one Godhead fans believe
that the religion of the semi kingdoms
might have been made by the night King
himself to make people worship the faith
of the seven and not the old gods of the
forest who are currently worshipped only
by the north because the old gods are
the only thing that can stop him hence
why the start start the best chance to
defeat the night King more close
supporting this theory come for the
seven-point star itself in that holy
text it stated that spirits and white
skin at karma pious man so long as his
armored in his faith as a devout priest
testing the religion of rather the Lord
of Light knows Sanchez said it's filled
with lies and many fans believe it was
filled by none other than the night King
interesting theory but I don't quite
like it
because I don't see much purpose in it
from visual photos and posters with a
bunch of theses let's move on new
details speak out about the greatest
battle sequence yet produced for
television the battle for Winterfell
that takes place in Episode three before
the huge battle there will be two
episodes not as intense but the fans
will not be let down
director David Nutter promises and
continues with their lot firsts in these
episodes
there's the funny sequence I've ever
shot on the show the most emotional and
compelling scene I've ever shot and
there's one scene where there's too many
major characters together it feels like
you're watching a super here
movie but of course there comes this
great episode where we'll witness a
battle sequence of unparalleled
proportions which required 11 weeks and
night shows it almost a thousand people
working on and in it third episode is
described as an uneasy collection of
allies against the night king and his
army everyone on set was paying
attention to the details there was one
scene ER Samos building a sword against
a bunch of whites Heber told the
producer that same looked badass you
hear what he just said the producer
announced the room that's the problem
Sammy's not supposed to look like a
badass so Bradley adjusted his
performance so that same looked more
awkward and confused as the whites came
at it
if only the producers lets em fight to
the fullest venom fell will still stand
for me civilians Arya Stark II was her
first real experience with the proper
Game of Thrones battle sequence which is
odd considering all the fighting her
character has done over the years
William said I skipped a battle every
year which is bizarre since I as the one
who's been training the most this is my
first taste of it and I have been thrown
in at the deep end other cast members
agree that the experience was the most
difficult thing in their lives everybody
prays they never have to do this again
said Rory McCann the Hound
at one point of shooting one anxious
fainted on set because of all the smoke
in the air one crew member had an asthma
attack and had to be taken to the
hospital there are many more details and
leaks we know about this greatest battle
sequence of all time but it's not new
and have already been heavily discussed
in my previous videos so if you want
even more spoilers make sure to check
out other leaked videos and as always I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace